[Música]
en guatemala' manifestantes tomaron el
congreso y le prendieron fuego a varias
oficinas hasta ser desalojados por
fuerzas de seguridad y cuerpos de
bomberos que apagaron el incendio
la toma tuvo lugar en medio de una
manifestación con el objetivo de
rechazar el presupuesto del estado para
2021 aprobado por el parlamento en su
mayoría oficialista- y presentado por el
gobierno de alejandro giammatei
comenzó la cumbre anual del g20 durante
el encuentro virtual de dos días los
representantes de los 20 países tendrán
como tema central determinadas
estrategias para impulsar la
recuperación económica y la distribución
de las vacunas contra el cubit 19 a
nivel mundial
[Música]
grupos de personas salieron a las calles
de francia para respaldar el llamado y
activistas por las libertades civiles y
grupos de periodistas que rechazan una
nueva ley de seguridad que está siendo
discutida en el parlamento y que tendría
como delito la divulgación de imágenes
de funcionarios policiales
muy buenas noches gracias por continuar
con nosotros en france24 sierra blanco
un gusto saludarlos comenzamos a este
informativo en guatemala donde
manifestantes tomaron este sábado la
sede del congreso y le prendieron fuego
a varias oficinas hasta ser desalojados
por fuerzas de seguridad y cuerpos de
bomberos que apagaron el incendio la
toma del congreso por 12 minutos tuvo
lugar en medio de una manifestación con
el objetivo de rechazar el presupuesto
para el año 2021 aprobado por el
parlamento en su mayoría oficialista- y
presentado por el gobierno del
presidente alejandro giammatei el
mandatario reaccionó a la manifestación
mediante un mensaje en twitter en el que
indicó que se tiene el derecho de
manifestar conforme a la ley pero no se
puede permitir que se banalice la
propiedad pública o privada
y es que previo a estos hechos el
vicepresidente de guatemala guillermo
castillo le pidió la renuncia de manera
conjunta al presidente llama tel
castillo dijo que le sugirió al
mandatario vetar el decreto del
presupuesto para el año 2021 el mayor en
historia del país y que llevara a un
serio endeudamiento de las arcas
públicas así como el rechazo de los
ciudadanos sobre la ayuda nos cuenta más
por el bien del país con esa fórmula el
vicepresidente de guatemala pidió al
presidente que renunciando juntos
asimismo admitió que no tiene una buena
relación con el mandatario y quien no
comparte muchos asuntos que forman parte
de la agenda del estado quiero dejar muy
claro el planteamiento que le he hecho
al presidente por el bien del país
que presentemos ambos nuestra renuncia
al cargo el de presidente y yo del
vicepresidente de la república pero que
lo hagamos juntos la declaración de
castillo se desató luego de una oleada
de protestas en redes sociales en contra
de la aprobación del presupuesto del
estado 2021 avalado por el presidente
alejandro giammatei el pasado miércoles
este presupuesto es criticado por sumar
endeudamiento y por haber sido aprobado
sin discusión en el congreso
casio también ha solicitado al
presidente que evalúen juntos las
carteras del estado para remover a
varios ministros minutos antes de que
castillo planteara la propuesta de
disolución del actual gobierno ya mate
ya había expresado su intención de
mantener vigente al presupuesto aprobado
debo aclarar que me sentaré con todos
los que sea necesario para explicarles
paso a paso el presupuesto 2021 y
aclarar dudas porque jamás en la
historia se ha presentado un presupuesto
menor al año anterior a diversos grupos
de la sociedad
a una manifestación este sábado para
mostrar su descontento a la aprobación
opaca de un presupuesto que según
especialistas prioriza la asignación a
infraestructuras pero descuida a la
población y sus necesidades
manifestación que como ya lo vimos se
terminó en el incendio de una parte del
congreso del país cambiamos ahora
información este sábado se celebró la
primera jornada virtual de la cumbre
anual del g20 las 20 economías más
poderosas del mundo debatieron sobre la
crisis económica provocada por la
pandemia del coi 19 y las medidas para
impulsar una recuperación inclusiva y
sostenible además se discutió sobre cómo
hacer accesible la vacuna contra el
virus
el informe de nuestra periodista andrea
maya
multilateralismo apertura e inclusión el
principal foro de cooperación
internacional celebró su primer día de
cumbre predicando repetitivamente estas
palabras en un discurso que le apuesta a
la lucha conjunta para rescatar al mundo
de los estragos de la crisis sanitaria
el objetivo durante este fin de semana
es consensuar medidas para centrarse en
una recuperación económica con la
promesa de que ésta sea justa y
sostenible el rey salman bin abdulaziz
de arabia saudita habló desde riad y le
dijo a los países participantes que el
desafío para enfrentar la crisis es de
todos
nuestros pueblos y economías siguen
sufriendo este impacto
sin embargo haremos todo lo posible para
superar esta crisis mediante la
cooperación internacional
la vacuna contra el cob y 19 y su
accesibilidad por los países menos
desarrollados fue uno de los puntos en
que coincidieron varios de los líderes
alemania insistió en una mayor inversión
en las instituciones multilaterales el
presidente francés señaló
la necesidad de evitar a toda costa el
escenario de un mundo a dos velocidades
mientras que el mandatario mexicano dijo
que la pandemia se debe combatir sin
afán de lucro la salud es un derecho
humano fundamental
que el estado tiene que garantizar
haciendo a un lado el afán de lucro
la atención médica
las vacunas y las medicinas
deben ser gratuitas los líderes de reino
unido y brasil se unieron al llamado de
cooperación mientras que uno de los más
criticados fue el mandatario
estadounidense quien participó en el
inicio de la cumbre y poco después se
fue a jugar golf pese a los más de 12
millones de contagios por kobe 19 y las
255 mil muertes que se han registrado en
eeuu
precisamente vamos hasta allá hasta eeuu
el gobernador del estado de california
gavin newsom impuso un toque de queda en
gran parte de su territorio para detener
el rápido aumento de los casos de kobe
19 la obligación de quedarse en casa
regirá desde hoy a las 22 horas e irá
hasta las 6 hasta las 5 horas al local y
permanecerá vigente hasta el 21 de
diciembre la medida entra en vigor
cuando eeuu supera los 12 millones de
casos de coronavirus de más de 250.000
muertos por dicha enfermedad
en francia a grupos de personas salieron
a las calles para respaldar el llamado
de activistas por las libertades civiles
y de periodistas que rechazan una nueva
ley de seguridad que es discutida en el
parlamento el proyecto penaliza la
difusión que se considere mal
intencionada de imágenes de las fuerzas
del orden luis méndez zúrich nos tiene
todos los detalles
con pancartas cantos y consignas miles
de personas salieron a las calles de
parís y otras ciudades francesas su
intención era expresar rechazo a una ley
que a juicio de activistas podría
atentar contra la libertad de
información y el libre ejercicio de los
medios de comunicación
efe con lo que este gobierno está
tratando es que dejemos de hacer esta
vigilancia para que los ciudadanos los
denunciantes los periodistas en posesión
o no de carnet de prensa se vean cada
vez más obstaculizados en la revelación
de las fallas del estado si eso sucede
es el fin de la democracia
efe así se está el primer ministro
francés yann castex indicó que la ley
que será votada en el congreso el 24 de
noviembre para luego pasar al senado no
afectaría a la libertad de información y
sólo se centraría en las imágenes
transmitidas con clara intención de
dañar a un policía de aprobarse la
legislación los responsables podrían
enfrentar penas de hasta un año de
cárcel y multas de 45 mil euros
woodward manifest es un ataque grave
contra la libertad de informar lo que
indigna es que hace dos semanas el
presidente defendió con fuerza la
libertad de expresión solo para venir a
pisotear la 15 días después en una
completa hipocresía del frío que la
pensión su hacer feliz porque si total
en julio pasado tres agentes de la
policía fueron acusados de homicidio
involuntario por la muerte del
repartidor cedric soviet un hecho que
fue captado en video por algunos
transeúntes en francia una parte de la
población teme que de aprobarse la nueva
legislación sea difícil identificar los
casos de abuso policial
un satélite de oceanografía que será
utilizado por la nasa y la agencia
espacial europea fue lanzado sin
incidentes a bordo de un cohete spacex
falcón line desde la base de la fuerza
aérea vandenberg el central sic se
utilizará para monitorear los datos de
la atmósfera y para ayudar a crear
modelos climáticos en el sitio web de la
nasa poco después del lanzamiento se
instalaron cámaras a bordo del cohete
falcon line que capturaron su separación
del centro xics hasta aquí en
informativa en france 24 continuará con
nosotros feliz noche para todos
[Música]